game was like
you know um he was in one of those
contracts with them near 10 years
and they tried to shelf him and i just
kind of used my resources
and who i was and what shook taught me
to do to get him out of that
with that like when you say what should
taught you to do we think of some of
those should night
antics that might have well you know i
don't think it was anti you know i think
sure gets the um
the short end of the stick because the
the uh persona
but if you was asked joe to see if you
was to ask you know mary jay
if you was asked the kid that did the uh
ice ice baby beat
about uh uh sug's business there to tell
you
all he did was make the wrong right
you know i mean should turn 30 cents
meaning the album selling for ten
dollars and the artist getting 30 cents
off the sale just crazy 230 percent
right he turned 30 cents which was the
old motown [ __ ] and all the old days
[ __ ] right
to 30 percent so now you're 30 cents and
it don't be a group
like the alcoholics trying to bring
those ten cents a piece
now he turned that to three dollars
right right
so um and i've
always seen suge try to deal with things
the right way
out the box but unfortunately um even in
america has been proven
you know our world we come from in these
violence
that's what people respect yeah you know
what i mean i hate to say it you know
what i mean like if you're walking down
the street
you see a yard that says beware a dog
and then another yard with the gate open
and you didn't made a decision you going
to somebody's backyard the mere
daughter that dog back there says you're
gonna go on it you're gonna go
with the gator yeah yeah you know what
i'm saying that's just the world we come
from
it's a reason why you know uh china
won't launch on us so we won't launch on
that we owe them people a lot of money
you know that trillions of trillions of
of the violence that could happen so you
know um
sometimes when you've exhausted
everything else
you know you got to go another way with
it and he only went there if you
force him to go there other than that he
was very protective of his family
and he was very protective of his
employees as well as
well as his artists